et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
gama la binah cofondateur du mouvement
des droits civiques bonsoir gamme
alabina merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés maxime tu y es beau tu es docteur
en droit bonsoir à vous également la
france qui semble donc assimiler l'islam
en général à la menace terroriste ont
bien de l'entendre de la bouche du
directeur général de la sérieuse ong
human rights watch gamme alabina ça vous
semble exagéré ou c'est effectivement ce
que vous avez pu constater ce que vous
constatez vous-même ni dans le sait ce
qu'on comprend qu'il ya une une analogie
entre 1100 et terrorisme à cause de
certains qui ont agi violemment et qui
se réclament de l'islam mais en vérité
c'est très exagéré ce qu'on généralise
une accusation à des gens qui n'ont
absolument pas pris parti pour l'immense
majorité à des actions violentes
donc effectivement je crois en la
logique en gaz là dessus qu'on comprenne
bien vous pensez vous que le
gouvernement français puisque c'est de
ça qu'il s'agit
il vise ce directeur général de human
rights watch la loi de séparatisme vous
pensez que la france justement fait
cette assimilation c'est votre avis
également il ya des attentes en
allemagne et en angleterre il ya des
attentes et un peu partout et
particulièrement en allemagne angleterre
ce qu'ils sont des pays comparables à la
france
ils n'ont pas ces deux lois nouvelles
qui cible la communauté musulmane ont
fait des ils ont juste appliquer les
lois de sécurité qui s'appliquent dans
tous les pays démocratiques à
destination de ceux qui ont commis des
actes de violence
en france il il reste pas lui faire des
lois pour cible est effectivement façon
très claire même si le disent pas façon
explicite ce qu'ils appellent la
communauté musulmane donc les gens qui
ce qui serait des pratiques musulmanes
qui serait vu comme musulman estime
maxime thibon vous portez le même regard
la france crée des raccourcis dont je
trouve que la france fait pas
spécialement des raccourcis moi je veux
pas tomber dans ce faux débat quant à
savoir si on a un amalgame entre les
musulmans et l'islam isme on sait très
bien que nombreux musulmans qui veulent
vivre leur religion
normalement en france qui ne supporte
pas l'islamisme et qui ne supporte pas
en réalité l'absence d'intervention
d'état pour mettre fin à un islamisme
radical et c'est ça le vrai problème
aujourd'hui
moi je pense que en réalité la loue
ne devrait pas s'appeler séparatisme
elle devrait s'appeler naissance de la
république parce que ce qu'on est en
train de vivre aujourd'hui c'est une
absence complète de la république et
c'est parce que la république c'était
face et que des groupuscules l'islamisme
radical tout un tas de groupuscules
viennent remplacer sur plan des valeurs
l'absence de république française est
donc en fait cette loi à mon sens on
pourra en parler mais si vous voulez on
ne fait pas en fait la république est du
droit on décrète pas la république ont
la vie et c'est un peu ce que je
regrette et je voudrais pas qu'on tombe
en même temps dans un fou discours à
dire que la france amalgame islam et
islamisme on sait pertinemment qu'il ya
une distinction
on sait malheureusement que des gens
passent de l'islam à l'islamisme qu'il y
a un lien naturel parce que le texte est
le même c'est à dire que
l'interprétation du coran n'est pas la
même mais on reste sur ce même texte
il s'est quand même mais on ne peut pas
passer à côté mais je ne voudrais pas
qu'on abaisse le problème aujourd'hui de
l'intégration ou bien tout simplement de
la lutte contre l'islamisme a simplement
fou amalgame avec l'islam gama labinal
ong du juge clairement notre laïcité
trop durs notamment évidemment vers
l'islam c'est de ça qu'il s'agit ça veut
dire qu'on serait moins tolérants avec
une religion qu'avec une autre en france
c'est votre avis également bien
évidemment qui est la tolérance mais je
vais répondre à ce qui vient d'être dit
d'abord c'est pas une loi sur le sur la
le séparatisme puisqu'on utilise plus
été retoqué la loi puisque conseil
constitue elle s'y était opposée
évidemment et à juste titre non c'est
une loi qui fait qu'il ment cible
conséquence le conseil des excuses mais
non c'est très juste cause et asthme
donc qui a retoqué pourquoi pas ce qu'il
dit qu'effectivement le caractère
stigmatisant alors j'aime pas le terrain
parce qu'il est très chrétien les
stigmates c'est jésus bref ces
caractères qui cible de façon claire les
musulmans au sens large 10 quoi il dit
que si quelqu'un parce qu'il ya toujours
le dirait le délit d'intention bas
poings liés dans des lits d'attention
mais plus dans l'atome dans l'action
dans la volonté d'agir mais dans la
tension et ça commence à poser pour
l'ania plusieurs textes dans ce projet
de loi mais en substance ce qui se passe
c'est que quand on dit par exemple que
il ya des volontés séparatistes d'une
population j'ai envie de dire simplement
que d'abord la séparation c'est un
principe républicain
on est séparés l'église et l'état
ensuite on a séparé paris à la banlieue
ensuite on a séparé paris et la province
bref la séparation les structures elle
elle est sociale elle est historique
évidemment puisqu'on a séparé l'histoire
de france 2 sont cogné à l'isthme et
tout cela ça crée des tensions et en
vérité pour faire très simple j'ai envie
de dire que le problématique qui se pose
aujourd'hui à nous c'est de ses devoirs
que rhône au poids du doigt une
communauté dans son ensemble et on
accélère un dégradation de la relation
du fond de ce qu'on appelait vivre
ensemble en créant ce genre de pointage
c'est que les gens même si
inconsciemment ils disent que c'est pas
pour nous évidemment on n'est pas des
terroristes ou quoi que ce soit mais
c'est vrai qu'à chaque fois qu'ils aient
une action violente
immédiatement on dit les musulmans ont
dit pas seulement maintenant c'est plus
en plus évident non plus seulement
islamisme et les musulmans ensuite
concernant la lecture du coran non il ya
un coran c'est vrai mais il ya quatre
écoles juridiques et des différents
courants de pensée radicaux dont
certains qui sont amies de la
trajectoire de l'arabie dit saoudite
effectivement ça pose moins de problème
pas c'est l'argent donc pour tout vous
dire en substance comment ça je suis
vraiment de rupture de relations
diplomatiques parce que c'est quand même
qui a généré tout ce qui est ce qui l
arriération la culture musulmane
mais encore une fois quand on dit qu'il
ya une volonté de séparation l'a
volontiers de séparation elle est de
fait l'abandon des quartiers sac les
quartiers ne voulait pas être séparés
mais j'en ai de vous dire par rapport à
août on veut proposer aux écoles par
exemple de plus faire décoller à la
maison mais l'école de la république qui
sont des écoles poubelle en banlieue et
je le dis malgré le fait que les profs
se bat ce sont des écoles poubelle sans
moyens quand vous y allez vous allez
dans une garderie gérante de délinquance
parce qu'on a tout fait pour les écarter
ça c'est un vrai problème de séparation
qui va falloir régler mexique est bon
que pense le docteur en droit justement
que vous êtes vous qui avez certainement
lu ce projet de loi séparatisme saleh
domérat de tout on retrouve par exemple
l'article 18 trimestre la reprise de
l'article 24 sur la loi sécurité globale
et yves allait porter atteinte à la
liberté de la presse et la liberté
d'expression donc enfin moi ce texte il
me gêne pour une raison simple c'est que
la république elle se décrète pas et là
où je vous rejoins alors on n'est pas
d'accord sur le constat mais je vous
rejoins c'est qu'en fait il ya plus de
république française c'est pas
séparatisme le vrai nom c'est c'est dire
qu'une république c'est à dire qu'on
intègre plus c'est à dire qu'on ne met
plus la méritocratie en place c'est à
dire que là où dans les banlieues
devrait agir pour replacer la république
on ne fait rien moi par exemple je suis
pour qu'on pour la mixité au sein de
l'école c'est à dire qu'il ya des quotas
qu'on puisse pas simplement mettre les
enfants devant lieu dans des écoles
poubelles qui les enfants de vos cartes
id dans des écoles de beaux quartiers
mais qui est une obligation de mixité ce
que font certains pays est ce que ne
fait pas la france moi je suis pour
l'établissement du service national
parce que je le dis je le répète en
permanence quand vous mettez le petit
mohamed de banlieue avec le petit kevin
de zones rurales ensemble pendant trois
mois et bien je peux vous dire que la
république qu'ils apprennent à vivre la
stv2 la cohésion ils vivent là ils
vivent la difficulté ensemble et il
n'est est comme ça ça permet de faire
mettre en fait des valeurs communes et
le problème aujourd'hui c'est qu'on ne
fait plus de mixité républicaine la
république en fait et la laïcité on en
parlait tout à l'heure sont devenus des
choses complètement terne sont devenus
des éléments inexistant des éléments
purement juridique et on a pu me de
chaleur il ya plus de spiritualité
derrière notre nation c'est à dire qu'on
rassemble plus les gens derrière quelque
chose qui devrait les dépasser et c'est
un c'est un problème qui est plus
globale en réalité c'est à dire que
l'absence totale de sacralisation en
tout c'est à dire que plus rien ne nous
dépasse
normalement la présidence de la
république devrait avoir une place au
dessus de tous elle devrait être un
vecteur de réconciliation nationale et
en fait on voit que président de la
république se rabaisse aux plus basses
polémiques et j'ai plein d'exemples
comme ça donc en fait ça prenne beaucoup
plus globale et cette simple loi ne va
rien changer l'âge serait intéressant
que du bon il ya une partie sur laquelle
vous rejoins f qui manque c'est le
travail provoquaient l'unicité
parce qu'aujourd'hui les commissions
d'attribution des hlm tout comme les
établissements poubelles ont toujours
été faits les relations en sorte de
mettre à la tipp à la périphérie de la
capitale ce qui gênait ceux qui étaient
trop colorée ça rappelle un peu le le
général le match a vu le maréchal
leclerc qui arrive en france
libérant la capitale il met ses lois ses
armes derrière pour ne pas libérer une
capitale pas ce qu'il a dit on ne peut
pas montrer aux parisiens qui l'ont
libéré par leur part l'or l'or alors
colonie clairement la couleur pose
problème et effectivement il ya une
responsabilité des états qui est très
lourde et même d'ailleurs macro l'avait
rappelé dans son discours il a dit
qu'effectivement il faut regarder les
choses en face on a abandonné circule
ces territoires ce qui me surprend
d'ailleurs chez vous c'est que vous
étiez un gilet jaune donc le discours
que vous tenez les discours auquel je
peux adhérer
sinon j'ai quand même temps vous avez
été écrit sur le gilet jaune c'est pas
la même griffe
vous aviez non vous aviez sympathie pour
eux quand j'ai visité les jours sans
tomber à tout le monde et gilet jaune
notre sympathie pour les mouvements
poker world kavanagh médias chinois vont
arriver là de ce point de vue il a
produit une analyse qui est intéressante
mais après arriver sur réponse qui est
au national tous gvt à ton front
national c'est surprenant je trouve ça
présentement d'un pare balles jeunes
surtout parce que vous avez la chance de
quand même de connaître un peu la halle
là bas j'espère pour vous et vous rendez
bien compte que la rupture française et
y ait rupture d'abord sociale ethnique
et que c'était planifié ce n'est pas un
hasard quand on l'a fait des aides que
les écoles poubelle ça ne regarde pas
parce que j'en ai connu logique
racialiste je suis pas du tout moi je
veux pas durant simplement sa fédération
qui n'ont pas su être qu'ils n'ont pas
être intégrée qui n'ont pas été
assimilée et ça c'est un vrai problème
c'est à dire que autant avec les vagues
d'immigration de portugais ou d'italien
qu'on a connus on a eu moins de
problèmes d'assimilation parce qu'on
avait une culture identique avec les
vagues qu'on a connue une hors maghreb
n'a pas du tout été la même chose parce
que c'est des religions différentes et
là où je pense que les années 70 sont
est un véritable échec c'est qu'on
aurait dû soudé ces gens là autour d'une
culture commune autour de valeurs
communes ne pas les pactes et dans les
banlieues et malheureusement c'est ce
qui a été fait donc je trouve ça
inadmissible dit non mais ça je suis
certain qu'on sera pas d'accord mais moi
je pense à notre une cage rhinois uno
arabe et je trouve ça ça commence à me
fatiguer c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on
a un point on crée des l'appel non mais
aujourd'hui on met un point on crée des
labels de diversité moi je connais pas
de diversité en france
je ne connais tu la communauté nationale
je ne connais que la communauté
nationale
non c'est bon mais dix années c'est pas
fini je retiens je m'habille long de
l'émission c'est au noir c'est pas un
problème maintenant que c'était d'abord
et puis quelques couleurs mais c'est moi
qui a réussi l'un des plus beaux
concours de l'état par son mérite et pas
par sa couleur chasse et j'en ai mal
pour une buse les gens leurs couleurs au
lieu de les rayonnages ameren cela
s'appelle une
cela s'appelle une exception on peut
réussir mais c'est pas été excellent à
gnrh et monsieur on a laissé à
l'université mais écoutez moi mon ex
femme affiche
ecoutez-moi monnaies que sa femme l'a
fait suivre de colette l'asean d'accord
des quartiers populaires je parle des
pauvres en général c'est soit des six
ambassadeurs de gens riches qui vont
même à temps pour un bon dirigeant de
ruraux et semi finis avant propose ce
mois ci son problème c'est sûr ils sont
ils ont marché les ya encore pire mais
bon revenons à nos moutons vous dit que
vous appartenez à cette terre
on se trouvait dit oui oui mais si vous
mais c'est par là on était arrivé vous
êtes dans une posture il est quand même
intéressant si vous écoutez donc vous
dites que vous n'êtes pas pour le
racialisme c'est un fait établi
politique quand contre le général
leclerc arrive en france
il met son immigration dr c'est
l'histoire qui parlent ensuite
l'histoire parle encore quand les
polonais arrivaient en france celui du
siècle dernier on les parque dans le
nord de la france parce qu'on dit qu'il
des portes de deux maladies pourtant les
polissons catholique dans l'établé
français quand les italiens arrivent
c'est les blousons noirs ils se font
massacrer dans les années 20 par ce qui
est effectivement un arrêt un député qui
est assassiné sa compagne est
certainement celle que assez peut-être
là on a pu les assimiler comme vous
dites termes très violents parce que les
simulations ça ne produit pas de belles
choses en général mais on a pu les
assimiler parce qu'elle pas encore de
crise économique majeure
quand les magrets baril en france à la
suite d'une guerre d'une défaite la
dernière défaite française dans une
guerre l'extérieur qu'est ce qui se
passe on arrive en 79 des gradins
oui consulter les mythes conséquence de
quoi vous conjuguez dégradation
conséquences économiques augmentation
effectivement avec le regroupement
familial de la présence maghrébine en
france et marginalisation des immigrés
sont mis sous mitterrand et 11h45 mixa
est bien là et va quoi à des tensions
qui se multiplient vous rajoutez à cela
les tensions internationales politiques
dans lesquels la france intervient liban
irak syrie mali lydie tous et tous ces
éléments constituent dans l'inconscient
collectif des jeunes maghrébins le
sentiment qu à la fois ils sont parqués
comme des bestiaux dans les gîtes dans
les banlieues mais qu'en plus leurs pays
d'origine ont droit à un traitement de
faveur militaire de bombardements c'est
cela la vraie problématique
en italie la défense
la réponse est le mot de la fin pour
vous maxime qui est bon non c'était
terrible aussi c'est qu'on a fait croire
aux gamins de banlieue qui pourraient
tous être zinedine zidane alors que la
réalité c'est une nouvelle chômage de
masse et donc malheureusement vu que
l'état abandonné on a eu l'augmentation
aussi l'intégration de l'islam radical
qui a su capter cette jeunesse en
déshérence et l'emmener vers un verre
des verts au final une commande vers
l'islam radical et sas énormément
n'ont ils rien n'a été fait dans ce sens
là et donc moi ça me dérange énormément
parce que c'est là où il faudrait agir
en réalité pour restaurer la république
dans nos banlieues
mais la république aussi elle doit être
intransigeante elle ne l'est pas je
pense et je le constate en fait avec
l'islam radical où elle ne lui pas
suffisamment où elle n'applique pas
suffisamment la loi merci en tout cas
tous les deux gammes alabina maxime qui
est bon d'avoir accepté ce débat sur rt
france